La Prof:
Frotte mieux que ça !
La prof:
Et range les par ordre chronologique !
La Prof:
Lucretia...
Non, rien.
La Prof:
Aliénor! On mange!
Télé:
"Nous pénétrons maintenant dans les jardins
du palais de Versailles, le cœur de la monarchie
française.
C'est dans le bosquet suivant que Marie-Louise
de Montmorency-Laval, duchesse de Roquelaure,
aurait savouré son premier chocolat chaud..."
La prof:
A ce soir!
Aliénor:
BON.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici?
Lucretia:
Nous déjeunons.
Aliénor:
Arrête avec l'humour, tu me fais peur.
La Prof est partie, j'ai bossé comme un serf
hier...
Je veux SAVOIR.
Très bien.
Lucretia:
Nous sommes arrivées trop tôt dans le futur.
Nous étions censées arriver au XXIIIe siècle,
et je ne sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé.
Nous sommes coincées ici.
Aliénor:
Pourquoi le XXIIIe siècle?
Lucretia:
C'est l'époque à laquelle appartient la
personne qui nous a contactées.
Tu n'en as pas de souvenir, mais c'est elle
qui t'as rendu visite
et t'as convaincue de faire le voyage.
Notre lointaine, lointaine descendante.
Aliénor:
Plus que la Prof, donc?
Lucretia:
Elle est bien plus évoluée que la Prof.
Elle appartient à une époque où les humains
sont capables de voyager dans le temps!
Mais seulement pour rendre visite à leurs
ancêtres.
Elle m'a expliqué que suite à une catastrophe,
ils ont perdu à peu près tout ce qui constituait
leurs archives, leurs mémoires...
Et son organisation, les cyber-historiens,
tente de recréer les traces de leur passé.
En recueillant le témoignage de leurs ancêtres.
Aliénor:
Donc on était censées voyager, dans le futur,
pour raconter nos mémoires.
Ils doivent entendre des récits passionnants,
ces historiens.
Lucretia:
Évidemment, notre lignée a bien perdu en
prestige à ton époque.
Mais moi, j'avais tellement de choses à raconter...
Avant de rentrer chez moi, ce qui n'est plus du tout d'actualité.
Aliénor:
Mais je comprends pas, pourquoi notre cyber-historienne
s'est pas contentée de nous poser ses questions
chez nous, au lieu de nous faire faire ce
voyage qui est clairement pas au point?
Lucretia:
Je lui ai posé cette question, et apparemment
il est dangereux pour eux de rester longtemps
dans le passé.
Ils ont peur de modifier leur avenir, une
histoire de papillons, je soupçonne qu'elle
ait essayé de m'embrouiller pour cacher qu'en
fait
ils ne maîtrisent pas grand chose à leur matériel.
Enfin, j'ai pas compris.
Aliénor:
Ça, ça a dû te faire mal de l'admettre.
Mais j'aurais été curieuse de voir le XXIIIe
siècle, ça aurait été...
Encore plus barré que cette époque, j'imagine.
Lucretia:
Tu n'aurais rien vu, tu aurais répondu à
ses questions dans une pièce neutre avant
d'être renvoyée à ton époque.
Mais rien ne s'est passé comme prévu, nous
sommes coincées ici,
tu ne te souviens de rien...
Et je veux trouver un moyen de rentrer chez
moi.
Aliénor:
C'est pas moi qui vais t'aider, hein, je sais rien.
Et puis, j'suis plutôt pas mal ici.
Paraît que j'ai une meilleure espérance
de vie, et j'sais pas ce que je ferais sans
Internet maintenant que j'y ai goûté...
Lucretia:
Geek.
Je me doutais bien que tu serais aussi utile
que d'habitude, mais est-ce que tu sais si
d'autres parmi notre lignée sont passés
par ici? Tu m'avais parlé d'une révolutionnaire,
un jour...
Il doit bien y avoir quelqu'un parmi nous
qui en sait un peu plus.
Aliénor:
Ouais, y'a eu pas mal de personnes, mais c'était
toujours pareil.
Ils apparaissaient un jour, et disparaissaient
le lendemain.
On est les seules à être restées.
A part peut-être...
Ça va pas te plaire.
Lucretia:
Dis toujours.
Aliénor:
Une pirate.
Lucretia:
Parmi nos descendants?
Par tous les dieux.
La situation peut
difficilement être plus cauchemardesque, alors continue.
Où se trouve cette pirate, maintenant?
Aliénor:
Aucune idée, mais elle est restée plus longtemps
que les autres, le temps de vider la collection
de rhum de la Prof, en fait.
Et puis elle a disparu.
Je sais que la prof l'a cherchée dans des
«PMU», mais elle a fini par
laisser tomber.
Elle est peut-être toujours dans le coin.
Lucretia:
Si elle est restée dans cette époque, il
faut la trouver.
Elle en sait peut-être davantage, et quoi
qu'il en soit être plus nombreuses
nous rendra plus fortes.
Si vis pacem, para bellum.
Je sens que je vais le regretter.
Il faut que tu partes à sa recherche.
Aliénor:
OUAIS! Mais pourquoi pas toi? Ça te ressemble
pas, j'suis sûre que t'as un truc derrière
la tête.
Lucretia:
C'est évident, tu ressembles davantage à
la Prof, et tu es plus informée que moi sur
les coutumes du XXIe siècle.
Tu n'auras qu'à lui emprunter quelques vêtements,
et tu pourras passer pour elle sans problème.
Notre duo fonctionne mieux ainsi, de toute
manière: je dirige, et tu exécutes.
Je superviserai les opérations depuis ici.
Aliénor:
Depuis ton canapé, j''suppose.
Super plan.
Si je mourais pas d'envie de sortir d'ici,
je te dirais que c'est un plan à la con.
Tope la!
Lucretia:
Très bien...
Faisons comme ça.
Aliénor:
Allons-y!
Lucretia:
Et ne fais pas de bêtises...
Pas plus que d'habitude...
Je vais le regretter.